María Elena rió sobrevivió a un intento
de feminicidio tras un ataque con ácido
en septiembre de 2019 hoy ya puede
volver a tocar el saxofón pero superar
la agresión ha sido tortuoso te ves muy
grave de salud
te encontrarás inactiva profesionalmente
te vas a deprimir y vas a estar
encerrada en tu cuarto quizá por años
por vergüenza
[Música]
según datos de la secretaría de salud en
la última década se registraron 797
amenazas o agresiones solo en 2022 hubo
222 amenazas y se perpetraron 47 ataques
con ácido o alguna otra sustancia por
ahora María Elena estudia música en
Ciudad de México pero debe viajar con
frecuencia a Oaxaca donde sufrió el
atentado para asistir a las audiencias
contra el presunto agresor creo que lo
más fácil hubiera sido callarme pero mi
agresor estaba amenazando de muerte
también a mi familia y creo que como
cualquier persona lo que menos deseamos
es vivir con miedo la diputada Marcela
fuente redactó una iniciativa de ley
para castigar con penas de 8 a 12 años
de cárcel y hasta 30 años se haya
agravantes este tipo de agresiones les
deja una serie de consecuencias físicas
psicológicas no solamente a ellas sino
sus familias Entonces les desgarran la
vida por eso es importante
promoverla como tentativa de feminicidio
las víctimas cuentan con apoyo de la
sociedad civil como la fundación Carmen
Sánchez que trabaja en conseguir ayuda
emocional y física para la
rehabilitación de la sobrevivientes
gestionamos convenios de colaboración
con el sector privado pero también con
público para acompañarlas en el proceso
médico psicológico legal pero también
propiciamos espacios de esparcimiento
social el caso de María Elena y su ardua
búsqueda de Justicia sigue inspirando a
otras víctimas y a la propia legisladora
a visibilizar esta problemática para que
las mujeres en México no sean atacadas
con ácido